alors en octobre dernier la reine avait
été hospitalisé mais ge qui n'a
repris les cours elle était fière
j'ai pris des cours elle va ça va mais
aujourd'hui elle est plus calme à rennes
va mieux elle va mieux mais elle est
repartie elle est oui elle se porte
mieux on a pu un à un ils étaient
plusieurs millions à suivre le discours
de noël d'elisabeth d'eau qui a été
diffusé le 25 décembre et vous avez vu
qu'en effet physiquement elle est très
très mal fini elle va mais elle va mieux
je sais je les veux y aller à la belle
américaine elle a maigri
babiche début et à la grille mais il a
vite à la maison
alors on va venir dans l'instant sur
tout ce qui s'est passé parce que l
avant tout de suite dû annuler sa
participation à certains événements
notamment la coop 26 oui ouais je sais
moi tu devais y aller
quel titre exactement vous deviez
dans le film a aussi annoncé la nouvelle
à la coop 26 à l'annuler muskin mois et
s'est très vite ça veut c'est un fort
il faut aller c'était christian assassin
ouais bah c'était l'année dernière
alors maintenant
elle va fêter en jouant 70e anniversaire
du règne 70e anniversaire
c'est vrai alors on va en parler de
reims tant il paraît que c'est une fête
de ouf c'est sûr plus dur avec moi c'est
historique est en effet trois jours de
festivités incroyable où les anglais ont
congé le gouvernement va à décrypter les
ongles y travaillerons pas avec
ce raisonnement sur le toit de
buckingham palace en concert sur le toit
de buckingham voilà joliette bout bah
j'espère oui enfin je suis à créditer
j'espère pouvoir y être à quoi vais je
suis pas seul le monde entière est
attendue plus ou mois à londres durant
jouette semaine plus ou moins de force
aller à londres alors si on n'est pas
invité ben oui parce que ça va être une
garden party le désigne al anglaise ils
vont rester dans le jardin tous et
toutes la semaine passée dans tous les
jardins de l'angleterre on a un million
de personnes
ailleurs il va faire le tour de tous les
jardins la sirama une fatigue et moushin
et pour vous donner une petite histoire
drôle et les français peuvent participer
sachez qu'il faut être anglais pour
faire ça il y à un concours qui est
lancé à l'heure actuelle si vous allez
sur le site du palais vous aurez toutes
les indications et on demande aux
anglais et à tous qui voudrait donc
pourquoi pas aux français de réaliser le
plus digne du jubilé le poly mois
publient les avait vus depuis 18 mois
le pudding jubilé tout dit sur la bbc ne
pas manger une recette qui vous plaît
qui est dur le différend là on peut lui
faire des pas d'ajouter il a
vraiment pu dire
quittant le nid qui touche pour l'année
et quoi et qui c'est qui va goûter mark
flanagan qui est vraiment le chef
salut chef des cuisines des minables
doit écouter tous les puddings fui la
zone folies en matière éthique
il va tout goûter leur classement oui
bon qu'il va recevoir des puddings du
monde entier malade il va surtout
recevoir les preuves et il va convoquer
cinq personnes d'après les comment dire
les recettes qui sont le plus
susceptibles de correspondre à la reine
de la fille de la fois l'adorent le
chocolat il est violet elle adore les
chocolats jose et les violettes ouais
ouais c'est moi monde et les fous et
dans des matches en l1 mais c'est vrai
que je voulais je fasse aux pouliches ma
vie ah oui sur l'a10 à faire un peu
digne je vais faire un pudding d'accord
et c'est moi qui le boot à web à frère à
mon avis on va lui faire manger
record à soixante dix ans et celle du
caire
historique en angleterre depuis 2015
elles dépassent le règne incroyable de
la reine victoria et presque historique
dans le monde entier ils ont très bien
réussi d'ailleurs ça oui alain trimestre
et ne tiennent plus le plus long
jean-denis soir
par le roi du swaziland ont poussé
l'euro dawkins oasis du soi-disant le
swaziland certains pays je connaissais
rien de tel chez oc ou de housses à côté
du swaziland où
j'adore alors est-ce que tout est déjà
prêt pour sa succession qui va succéder
à la reine elizabeth pour sa succession
mais voilà vous savez il se penche
beaucoup sur le jubilé a pas pour
l'instant il aurait on y aura des jours
à des joueurs de foot turin zidane tout
ça
sheeran est attendu dans le toit de
mieux qu ils l'assurent elton john elle
peut donc pas de la famille royale et
m'a tuer dont elle est très fière
absolument je te prends-tu jugé qu'elle
me thomas d'elle la turquie rêve savais
que je faisais que elton john est un
grand ami de mathieu de l'envié d'un à
passer un week-end je vous jure que
c'est vrai il a passé un week end c'est
juste après qu'elle écrit ça que fight
[Applaudissements]
l'acquis d'autres la
mairie villard
mccartney les beckham évidemment vont
être atteints du tout c'est big eye pet
un petit col et la prédication le début
la vraie question mais là je suis à toi
est-ce que c'est megan seront présents
s'assurera ça on en n'est toujours pas
sûr et ça chez moi si tu veux pour faire
la blague je peux passer en mégane
[Rires]
une question est posée par le sun vous
savez que la couleur des robes
d'elizabeth ii est quelque chose qui est
vraiment scrutées par les anglais il
adore ça et bien aujourd'hui le seul
enfin dans l'édition de la semaine
ossuaire disait en effet il y à deux
questions que les anglais se pose quelle
est en effet la couleur de la robe que
la reine margot rire et surtout est-ce
qu'elle sera présent durant ces cinq
jours de fête
et avoir une absence de la reine parce
que vos questions que se pose est donc
actuellement mais dans le kobe a eu
c'est quelle robe à porter
je devais la montagne où il allait loi
sur les collèges explique-t-il non ils
n'ont pas de prob est confiné nom est
attendue à la rentrée les
adresses enfin elisabeth tous là ils
sont pragmatiques ouais c'est vrai
j'aime bien les anglais aimerait tenter
des fip en anglais
j'adore le roi de belgique elle est
belle je vous aime beaucoup aussi un jeu
c'est l'adrénaline la même si on est
très suivi pourquoi de belgique on
embrasse donc philippe s'appelle
philippe philippe savry que les caméras
du monde entier vont être braqués sur
l'autre et on attend une parade une
festivité absolument à mickey
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
mieux que ça il y aura une femme cavani
sa vie entière à la couronne qui aura 87
cents à ce moment des
faits
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
en france toujours un bonhomme ne
manquent pas mais je peux pas mener avec
toi là bas en juin une barque à la voilà
tu vas être accréditée toi mais jouit je
vois en toi je vais les demandes sont
faites je veux pas être une
petite histoire peut-être il ya
tellement de monde attendu normalement
l'église qui est retenue c'est tout le
temps westminster par par tradition des
bals à ce ne sera pas mesrine cela que
ce sera paul même pourquoi pas ce que ça
va pas le plaindre cueillir près de 4000
pour la cathédrale saint paul alors que
oui ce ministère ne peut en attendre que
2000 donc vous voyez le retentissement à
savoir vincent collet donné envie de me
battre nadal à 4
miles à l'heure mais 6000
sévère qu'on est venu on va y aller
ensemble jean-michel bien
c'est sympa les gars peut tenir à
ce ministère je vais la cale sellal a
commenté l'abbaye des grands événements
et on trouve des couronnements c'est la
stèle a été courue né à près de 70 ans
peur westminster